[Music]
justin timberlake uh was getting roasted
online
uh for this dance he did at a recent
concert in dc do you remember remember
the style beat your feet oh yeah yeah
what does that look like so it's a super
like dmv dc style
um and it's super dope back on abdc i
think what
yeah beat your feet kings these dudes
came out and they were like we met them
and they were super cool and they're
like is it a dance crew yeah they beat
your feet you beat your feet and we were
like what is that and they did it was
like we've never seen that before at all
what do you do you just like [ __ ]
that's it literally dude you would think
but on b it's on beta
you ever seen that style beat your feet
no not really it's actually or maybe i
haven't i didn't know that that's what
it was called it looks great it looks
kind of like an example it looks kind of
shook like footwork-ish sort of yeah
chicago footwork yeah i feel like it was
structured in a slightly different way
though
yeah it was like oh what is this so um
the funny thing is that justin
timberlake doing that concert in dc like
wanted to like i don't know like look
cool yeah homage and so like at one
point in the concert he like does a
little dance break and he just goes like
yo dc beat your feet and he starts doing
it
first i'm gonna show you what it's
supposed to look like
oh yeah
this is good that's good cause justin
timberlake's known to be a good dancer
too right yeah he's [ __ ] great
beating your feet he's really [ __ ]
good because i think people i think i
saw the clip of him and they uh they
made a meme of him doing this and they
they overlaid some like kids music and
they saw him
that's when i saw him but i didn't
really see uh the whole dance i'm
curious to see what the beast that's
dope he's touring again is he doing suit
and tie i don't know because it's during
because they're not awesome
like 20 20.
and then he did man of the woods and
then yeah here's an example this is uh
so even the music that they're dancing
to is very like dc it's like a specific
they have a very specific like scene
right yeah they're subculture that's
like that's what it is
so um i think one of these guys his name
is crazy legs with z crazy
how does the real crazy legs feel about
that
he has an s
oh i've seen this yeah
a lot of people take little bits of this
nowadays yeah
people have yapped lots of [ __ ] from
beat your feet but without even like
saying and knowing what it's from it is
a dc style yeah it's a dc culture the
music too i feel like like go go yeah
yeah yeah because it really fits there
and now here's the justin timberlake
version the real this is the real one
he looks like a substitute teacher here
yeah also his wardrobe wasn't really
helping with that
[Laughter]
oh no
it's like even a dad dude
i could see like hints of it
yeah he's trying so you got hate for
that he needs to be more wiggly he
didn't get hated he just got roses and
people were just like dude you're like a
dad yeah because it's his movement's
like oh that's fine
dc people were like bro how dare you say
beat your feet and then commence river
dancing
because like the setup i think it was
what got him yeah he was like hey y'all
beat your feet and everybody was like oh
is he gonna do it it's one of those
things that it's if you're gonna like
shout out such a specific subculture of
dance
it's a hard you better [ __ ] knock it
out the park it's really hard because
not only is it it's hard to
differentiate unless you're like you
really like know it but it's gonna be
really [ __ ] easy to do it wrong yeah
yeah did you practice it a little bit jt
that's the question i mean it's like
locking like that's really easy to look
like you're [ __ ] up you know like
that's what you think locking is
oh that's like two great examples
[Laughter]
oh he's got the point lock your feet
king oh this looks like you're about to
[ __ ] hail hydra but see the the worst
thing from my perspective isn't that he
did it badly it's that a guy like him
has a whole [ __ ] team of people to be
like you probably shouldn't do that
or to be like hey we're in dc let's hire
some actual beachy feet people to just
come on and do [ __ ] the real [ __ ] and
then shout it out it was a spur of the
moment thing i think he was like yo dc
beat your feet and go oh dad this beat's
kind of slow bro
he's like this beat is slow dude all the
stage hands on the back were like [ __ ]
he's doing it god damn it we didn't
rehearse this no i think at that level
too everyone kind of becomes yes man
so even if he said hey i'm we're in dc
i'm thinking of this
most of them be like that's a great idea
oh shoots people would love it exactly
perfectly yeah it's only like an account
oh uh
outside of lmfa or like have you been on
tour with other groups right like done
dancing for like for ourselves yeah ask
questions like who are is there big
people that you've collaborated with
like [ __ ] it's laingie on or something
yeah and have you seen how their team
like operates they're like y'all do this
[ __ ] oh yeah dude yeah like and if
everyone's like yeah that's [ __ ]
dealt dude for nba all-star we were
doing this thing with usher um
and then in that's crazy in uh in
rehearsal we did this thing where we
like built this like kind of position
and then he was supposed to front flip
over us usher confront friend and then
he was he was doing that song uh he goes
do you really want more
and he like lands the flip and then goes
more and then uh we were like that's so
tight and then um his choreographer or
manager was like i don't think that's
safe it's too much of a risk if you
don't land it you know that that'll just
look bad and we were like that's a
pretty safe call and then so he was like
no i really want to do it so we go for
like the first stage rehearsal like the
last one before the show
and then we do the thing boom and he
flips over and you see [ __ ] lands on his
back and he's laying us back going
really well
he sold it dude no but the fact that he
wanted to and just do it we gave you so
much respect because it's not necessary
he could just jump over and call it a
day yeah but so did he execute it on the
no they took it out they took it out
because they were like dude that's like
too much of a but then like good choice
though but then that probably happens
all the time like this artist just want
to push the boundaries yeah for sure
that happens artists are like oh we want
to we want to do that because like also
usher can do it he doesn't want to look
like he can't do it like we get it
because he should have used a body
double
we can have steve
toronto
[ __ ] asian guys
shortly
but it was always like really
crazy to us because we're like usually
we always assume the artist would go i
don't want to do that i don't want to do
this i just want to stand there but that
dude is opposite he's like i want to do
this one i want to like hang with these
guys oh my god amazing yeah
those are the best so the best artists
are always trying to like push farther
than even the choreographer feels
comfortable because in my performances i
always feel like i have to push harder
than like my team you know what i mean
and uh sometimes i get pushback from
that anthony's like no no
jackson wayne training at jam oh yeah
yeah yeah and i'm like
[ __ ] i don't know he was capable all
that crazy [ __ ] with andy he's such a
hard worker huh he's like wow
i worked like a good amount that fool is
psycho it's like all right again let's
go again let's go again and he's in his
40s huh no no he's down he's in his 20s
wait why did that [ __ ] go asian don't
raise him real good
jackson pollock
no i thought he was like an old school
chinese pop star that's why oh yeah he
just sounds like a hong kong pop singer
so i made up in my mind that he was
really famous in the early 2000s and
he's still grinding out and it's like
wow in the 40s like it is andy lau yeah
jackson jackson wing's a singer because
i think i saw him on your story or
something yeah he's a uh he's a very
very very [ __ ] popular uh singer he
was on got7 for k-pop but he also like
did his own like debut uh albums and
stuff in like china and stuff what would
you say is his american equivalent so an
idiot like nick could understand yes for
jackson wang
dang i honestly think jacksonville is a
mogul like a tom holland or even above
that like a jay-z are we talking the
musical industry i'm just talking about
like overall influence yeah
because he does what he's like he does
he does movies and music right is he
like justin bieber maybe combine two
people he's like an earlier version of
the rock wow
he's on that track yeah because he's
doing so many different things he's got
like his team weighing stuff he's got
like he's like opening studios and
training facilities he's got he's got
got7 he's got his individual stuff with
like different countries he's got his
albums is all english now you know what
i'm saying uh and he's jumping into
different movies and stuff like that but
he's like he's in his early 20s and he
was like olympic level fencing right
wow yeah his parents are like olympic
athletes and stuff like that he's
olympic level fences that's where the
work ethic comes from his parents are
olympic athletes yeah
in fencing uh just different things and
stuff yeah jackson wang dude i feel like
i think we should get to know this dude
yeah
yeah he could bring him on the show yeah
he's cool if he wants to and then just
have nick ask all the questions
so i heard you like the rock
why do people say that joke be like oh
wow can't believe you're in the 40s
[Laughter]
uh actually what is your [ __ ] routine
bro cause like i want to look like you
yeah remember even like the rock or
something like that one like double
platinum with moana track you know what
i mean so he's already got like a grammy
and [ __ ] like that too and you're like
what the [ __ ]
it's all about pride it's all about
power
i don't like that i don't know about
that song
i don't know about that i like you're
welcome
you're welcome that's my way better dude
you never see moana dude oh in the
[ __ ]
i don't watch cultural films wait he's
saying i'm moaning yeah bro that's
really his whole maui character him
singing the whole the whole he won like
a grammy for him i didn't know i don't
know i didn't know that yeah it went
like [ __ ] platinum plus or some [ __ ]
like it's it's that song is a banger bro
welcome you're welcome couple's journey
is ridiculous i want to try his french
toast spot though he has a french toast
place yeah where the rock not jackson no
no i'm talking about moana's guy oh yeah
yeah
what was it well it's an actual
restaurant or it's his
no i think it was like his his cook
would always make it but then they
opened up a shop recently that's cool
but it's like he would eat it on his
cheat day or something it looks insane
so i can't eat it right now obviously i
like french stuff i love french toast
just regular french toast and the rock
is so good man yeah but he's no jackson
wing i'll tell you that there you go why
why do you what do you know about
jackson wayne he he was going to the
olympics for a fencing dude oh [ __ ] so
you need to start listening to jackson
wang because i think we need to get
updated with the coup i'm gonna go hang
out at jam and see if he's there bro
when i first met him oh my god when we
were training we would always watch
these videos and i watched you guys
questions halloween videos that's so
embarrassing that's so random
that was not one that i would show
someone oh no the the hospital one yeah
yeah i wouldn't oh i know you're talking
about i wouldn't really be like hey
jackson wang check this out
it's like that's so random he's such a
fan of dance though like an authentic
fan of dance he's like a good dancer too
so he seems like a person that's like
legit trying to be good at everything
like the right way yeah yeah that's why
he's watching us and working with you
[Music]
you